Oh what the [ __ ] is this
it's my black blue oh my god you can see
this little red son-of-a-bitch on there
how do you get him to bite me
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
whatever it's not me and Channel
the other night I put a black widow
spider in my mouth
[Music]
the problem with Black Widow venom as it
gets all through your system and yet
like a pancreatitis you like what has
caused this systemic rash you have to
take all this and a van and seven some
it's not pretty
I did buy you know I tried like crazy
[Music]
nedda Justin Brown Justin Brown mm-hmm
so gladly pulled over
[Music]
man
maybe some are a little bit
[Music]
there's this top-secret Facebook app
that's only for celebrities and athletes
and I got invited to be a part of it and
when I said yes Facebook asked me to
come and meet with them so here I am at
their LA offices and this is pretty cool
and know what that stands for that's
just full of the secret team North
Carolina during the fall come on so
we're walking around Utah just try and
find some holiday meals I know what the
hell that yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
this is really [ __ ] cool there's a
deer in my backyard
[Music]
there's gonna be a skateboarding fans
here we are in Syracuse New York as you
can see the human slingshots being
pulled back I'm getting lunch while
hockey players all around the arena fire
bucks at me yeah
[Applause]
someone got a good shot on my hand
someone got a good shot on my elbow and
someone [ __ ] up my me it was a great
success less than 24 hours
oh [ __ ] do not want to miss what happens
in Morocco now the way here to subscribe
right here and get ready it's [ __ ]
awesome
it's [ __ ] awesome